he won't stop until he destroys half the
universe everything you know everything
you love
it will all be gone together
we can stop flannels
[Music]
you don't want to try
but we will
[Applause]
[Music]
hey everybody we got a whole bunch of
New Avengers to break down let's do it
we finally get better shots of Corvus
glaive and Proxima midnight we also see
Black Widow taking down Corvus glaive
with Proxima midnight spear remember she
can control the density of that so it's
almost like hitting someone with the
mass of a dying star it's crazy but
remember it's a movie so they tune
things a little bit differently from the
comics so I'll try to explain what's
going on and I've gotten a lot of
questions about what's going on with
this torch scene but if you're finding
me for the first time be sure to
subscribe to get all the Marvel videos
I'll name a new giveaway winner at the
end of this - we've seen a lot of
different angles of this Scarlet Witch
vision battle they're trying to protect
him because the Black Order have come
for the mind gem you could see him
slumped against the entrance to the tube
they're just like oh god with Scarlet
Witch just standing right in front of
him like she's getting ready to lose her
[ __ ] or something like that like if she
hasn't already she's getting matter in
matter by the time that they get to
Wakanda but it sounds like based on the
way the actors talked about it they get
their asses knocked around for a little
while before Captain America and his
Secret Avengers show up so you have
Black Widow you have Falcon we've seen a
little bit of Falcon trying to find out
Proxima midnight and I'm guessing he's
wearing some kind of harness because
he's able to actually kick her and it
actually makes a difference remember all
of fantasies children the Black Order
members are crazy powerful now some are
more powerful than others like Cole
obsidian is obviously their version of
the Hulk Proxima midnight Courbet's clav
are more like melee dps many mods like
their castor so they have their own dark
raid they're on a quest to take the
Infinity stones so you have to imagine
that the video game mechanics have been
flipped like you think of The Avengers
as a raid group they come together to
take down a boss but in an infinity war
it's Thanos who's questing to take
something from them so they're the boss
that Thanos is group is trying to take
down so it's just a funny way of
thinking about the movie because most
people will probably go see this and
think oh you know the Avengers they're
the heroes of this movie but really the
way that they wrote it is that Thanos is
the hero of this story
he thinks at least that he's saving half
the universe by killing half of all life
in it that's one of the things that
makes him so dangerous that in the fact
that he's super powerful is that he
believes his quest as righteous he's
doing the right thing because he's seen
all these terrible things
happened to his own people on his home
planet of Titan the scene where Black
Widow says we don't want to kill you but
we will is them talking to the black
order members I'm assuming that it's
both Proxima midnight and Corvus glaive
I don't think that they kill one of them
during this scene but I wouldn't be
surprised if they knock off some of the
members of the Black Order during this
big battle in Wakanda
now there's the battle on Titan that's
obviously with fan OHS we don't know who
else from the Black Order is going to be
there or if it's just going to be Thanos
but we still don't know who the voice
actor is playing the black order members
are they tease that they would be very
recognizable voices like people said
that Kevin Conroy would be doing the
voices for one of the characters
remember Batman from Batman the Animated
Series that would be so badass I can't
confirm any of that and we might not
even get any of that until the movie
comes out like they might just not give
us any footage with the black order
actually speaking so you pick and choose
your trailer moments really it's just
the superfans that want to hear stuff
from the black order most people are
going to see this movie that our big
comic book readers have no idea who
these people are
so Marvel probably doesn't feel a great
need to give people a lot of them in
these trailers that they're dropping you
get a little more of a Koi a during this
big battle with the outriders I wouldn't
be surprised if they changed the movie
just a little bit given the success of
black panther like holy crap people love
this movie let's give them some more of
these characters they even did that
during the Black Panther movie before
Black Panther came out the actors that
rebelled against him and said you know I
thought you'd be different from your
father but you're the same thing so he
helped kill monger take over the country
he actually had a much smaller role but
because he wasn't get out in that movie
blew up people are like oh wow they
really loved this actor let's give them
more of him so they changed the story
just a little bit to give him some more
scenes when Kimora is talking to someone
here people are like as she talking to
Thor what's going on because they've
been trading the voiceover and the
different trailers like usually Thanos
voice-over leads one of the trailers in
time you will know what it is to lose
then some of the trailers lead with
Gamora
talking about Thanos he can wipe out
half of all life with a snap of his
fingers so I love the way that they're
using those two characters perspectives
to tell the story of the movie like we
said it's Thanos movie Gamora is
probably the most important character
to Thanos so it makes sense that if
you're gonna use him to tell the story
of the movie then she would be the other
character that you used to tell the
story of the movie - I think I talked
about it in a previous trailer why she's
so important to him like you get a
little bit of it during the trailer -
when she's holding his hand as a child
she along with Thanos says people are
kind of his emotional through-line so we
might get a little bit more that during
the trailers but I'm just really
interested to see what the future of her
character is given what Thanos needs to
do to get the soul gem but given the
level of beard on this person here it
looks like she's talking to Peter quill
when she's got this voice over this
might be before they found Thor this
Thor scene where he says together we can
stop fan oohs it looks like he's trying
to plead with someone and the Guardians
already dead set on stopping Thanos so I
don't think that Thor is pleading with
the guardians in this scene here this
actually might be on the Dwarven space
Forge and he might be talking to the
dwarves trying to get them to help build
his new storm breaker weapon or give him
the technology or teach him how to do it
there's still a lot of mystery with that
storyline but most of the Thor stuff
we've seen so far is just him wrestling
with the guilt of surviving this
encounter with Thanos we you know we
still don't know exactly what goes down
with Loki although I think most of the
big theories are pretty solid still a
big question mark about what happens to
the rest of the Asgardian people but I
have a feeling that there's like a
couple quick moments where Loki and Thor
are able to save at least some of them I
don't think that they would spend an
entire movie trying to save the last of
Thor's people just to wipe them out in
the first five minutes of somebody
else's film there was a rumor that Chris
Hemsworth the actor was a little upset
with the Russo brothers because they'd
sort of rewritten his character as old
Thor instead of the new Thor that they
turned him into during Thor Ragnarok so
I don't know if there's any credence to
that or if it's true but Thor looks
pretty serious during the course of this
infinity war trailer so it does sound
like there's an element of truth in
there but I don't think that we expected
Thor to watch a lot of his people die at
Thanos's hand or even potentially his
brother Loki then walk away cracking
jokes but I mean they do have that funny
moment with the guardians so I think
that most of the Thor comedy
we'll come through adolescent Groot who
just doesn't give a crap about any of
this still playing his video game in
rocket who's still used for mostly
comedy but I think he can kind of
vacillate between being really serious
when he's trying to take someone down or
when he's commenting on the action
wipers wipers I cannot wait to see the
behind the scenes for all this that they
put on the DVD like I'm actually really
hoping that they released that sooner
rather than later but usually they wait
till a couple of weeks after the movie
comes out before showing you some of
that stuff speaking of which people
still asking about the Avengers for
title the Russo brothers said that they
would give a good long time to let
infinity war settle in people's minds so
I'm guessing they're gonna wait till the
comic-con panel this summer in July to
reveal what the title for Avengers 4 is
the only thing I've taken off my list of
possibilities is Secret Wars because it
feels like they would save that for like
a big x-men team-up when they eventually
get all the x-men characters settled in
whatever the future of the Marvel
Cinematic Universe is going to be and
I'm starting to lean away from the
Infinity Gauntlet like Avengers Infinity
Gauntlet because James Gunn even said a
long time ago that that's not what it's
called Infinity Gauntlet so I wouldn't
be surprised if they changed their minds
at the last minute usually when they
don't tell you what the title of a movie
is is because it's potentially a spoiler
which Kevin Feige says isn't that big of
a deal he said it's not that big of a
spoiler or two because they want the
freedom to change their mind at the last
minute usually titles get market-tested
so if they find out that Infinity
Gauntlet is too confusing or not
exciting enough a concept for casual
moviegoers then they'll come up with
some other title but what'll happen next
is they just dropped a new Westworld
season 2 trailer so I'll do a video for
that next should be up in a couple hours
then my Krypton episode 2 video a lot of
stuff happening today so just check my
Twitter feed for updates it's awesome
emergency I'll paste a link in that top
pinned comment if you guys don't know
where my twitter is but congratulations
to the giveaway winner from my last big
video Captain Ireland please private
message me so I can get your contact
details I'll name a new winner when I
post new Marvel but click here for that
other big Avengers trailer and click
here for the new Deadpool trailer and to
learn about the cancelled
Deadpool series and all that drama with
Kluber yesterday morning thank you so
much for watching everybody stay awesome
I'll see you guys tonight
[Music]